Vladimir Putin is one of the most powerful men in
the world and his lifestyle reflects his status,
His secrets and luxuries are as interesting as they are fascinating.
His personal fortune is said to exceed $70 billion and he has
access to a number of luxuries and amenities that very few can afford.
Among his hobbies,
Putin boasts an impressive collection of
luxury watches and high-end sports cars,
but most impressive of all is his impressive collection of properties,
including a luxurious residence in souchi,
a $57 million villa.
How does Putin manage to maintain his luxurious lifestyle?
If you are by the lives of the rich follow us to
discover more about how the world's most powerful men live.